professor thanks so much for coming on
so if you add this up and again we just
presented a bunch of different specific
examples
if we had four hours we could probably
get more comprehensive but you're seeing
the core institutions of american life
destroyed by this one mandate which
you know by itself is a challenge an
insult really to american liberty but in
its effect it's going to render
inoperable our hospitals our airlines
our police departments our fire
departments our long-term care
facilities i mean fill in the blanks
what else is there that's our society
and none of it's going to work very soon
what's the point of this i wonder
i don't know it's part of a lot of
policies tucker and it's not tucker
carlson that's saying this alone it's
right barack obama that says the border
is unsustainable
or
larry summers says the economic agenda
won't work our senators on the
democratic side said afghanistan is a
disaster
so it's everybody is saying
what's going on we've never seen
anything like it we've read about the
buchanan presidency and we've some of us
lived through the carter so was it
incompetence accidental is is it
non-compost mentos problems with the
president or was this by design an
anarchy a chaos a nihilism that was sort
of never let a a crisis go to waste
during this tragedy of 2020 to have a
an agenda that doesn't pull in any of
its items 50
but through the sheer fear
of this chaotic anarchic anarchistic
we're going to have a new agenda that's
socialist and nobody knows but they do
know one thing tucker that
the academic world and the abstract
world is not just parlor games it
matters that critical race theory that
we wrote off as you know racism
is necessary to fight racism nobody
would believe that we thought or new
monetary theory print money and you get
prosperity or critical legal theory that
there's no connection between innate
natural law and real law we said nobody
would believe that and then suddenly
they woke up
and we see that district attorneys are
letting people go off uh scot-free after
committing felonies or we've got zero
interest at a time we've got six percent
annual inflation so they're thinking
this is starting to affect us there's no
there's no there's nothing in the shop
at the shelves at walmart or maybe
target's not going to have christmas
presents or i don't want to walk out in
new york at night so
the academic world has filtered down to
the concrete world under this agenda and
they're really really frightened and
they're saying we've never seen
something like this before and when they
look to these institutions you mentioned
they look at the military or
professional sports or entertainment or
hollywood or silicon valley or social
media or network news or wall street or
or the corporate boardroom they say what
happened we don't recognize this anymore
we've been asleep and they've been
they've filtered into all of these
institutions with this agenda that we
don't want and it doesn't work and so
they're in a panic and i think just to
end tucker there's going to be a
reckoning and i think people whether
they're mexican-american communities on
the border
or where i live or soccer moms that are
mad about what's being taught in the
school it's a it's a it's not a top-down
woke revolution it's a grassroots
populist revolution we're going to see
it in the next midterms and i think a
lot of these institutions are going to
rule the positions that they've taken
and the damage they've done
looking back when hospitals told people
that they couldn't hold the hands of
their parents or spouses or children as
they died because of kovid
and no one
pushed those people out of the way and
said no it's my parent i'm going to hold
her hand as she dies when people put up
with that
i wonder if you can come back if you can
assert
you know your value as a human being
once you've already allowed them to
separate you from your parents as they
die
it seems like i don't know can we come
back from that
i hope so i believe that was what was
great about america we're building a
middle class citizenry with a pragmatic
practical sense and they're saying if
our leaders say no mass one mass to mask
herd immunity 60 70 80 90
no gain of function research at the
virology lab in wuno then they've lost
credibility and when they say there's no
such thing as really natural acquired
immunity you all got to get vaccinated
even if you've had coke i think that
people are saying i want to believe them
but i can't believe them anymore and i
want to use common sense and it's
starting to coalesce and it's really
terrifying the left i don't i don't
think i've seen them ever more terrified
i think that's and people should should
insist on common sense don't let them
separate you from your loved ones in
their final moment period each according
to a state each person
absolutely each according to a station
has to speak out
i think that's right victoria's hands i
appreciate it great to see you tonight
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else